all right our draft today Achilles heels
that could derail a team season in 2019
we have gotten rid we have we have
matured past we've evolved beyond the
coin toss we now use a trivia question
today I asked it you answer it here it
is big cat which kicker has the best
field goal percentage in the NFL
since 2016 I mean Justin Tucker feels
like the obvious answer here it's Robbie
gold former bears kicker who I walk of
85 for a ninety six point five
percentage that means I get the first
pick and sometimes it's great to have
the first pick because the first pick is
so obvious it's been the story of the
offseason it comes right off of the
double Doink the Bears can't find a
kicker
Eddie penny arrow is currently their
best option he won't be their kicker two
weeks from tomorrow night it's gonna be
somebody I just don't know who maybe
it'll be Morten Andersen the Bears
kickin situation is the number one
Achilles heel that can derail a team
season in 2019 that is that's a terrible
pick that's a terrible yeah yeah the
obvious pick is a terrible pick no how
about the obvious pick Andrew Luck's
health Mike that would be the obvious
pick that's my first pick we don't know
what's going on with Andrew Luck you
said yourself the Colts have superbowl
aspirations they came back last year and
we're fantastic they had a dynamite
draft lot you know in 2018 Andrew Luck's
health is the most important and biggest
Achilles heel for a certain team the
Colts can win their division very easily
if he's healthy all year if he's MVP
caliber Andrew Luck but we don't know so
that is the Achilles heel that season
ends if the Bears miss a couple kicks
their season isn't over if Andrew Luck
doesn't play their season is officially
over yeah I don't know how much Greek
mythology they teach at Wisconsin but
you need to brush up on what the
Achilles heel is Andrew Luck situation
is far bigger than that one little
weakness at the bottom of the foot it's
the whole leg it
the whole lower half of his body we
don't know what the hell is going on
with him it's much bigger than an
Achilles hill and all those they have
jacobi percent and they kind of believe
in him for the bear is fit this
perfectly because they got everything
else they're the team that everyone in
Vegas is betting on to win the Super
Bowl but they got that one little flaw
that they can't quite fix and it's
fitting because it deals with the foot
it's the back of the foot that's it so
the Bears are the much better choice I
don't want to get a whole lawyer thing
with you but the Bears are the much
better choice Andrew Luck literally is
dealing with a foot he I think it might
even be an Achilles heel injury it went
from his calf to his ankle it's litter
my great Achilles heel yes it's the
injury is mobile it has moved down from
his kneecap to the bottom of his foot
all right round two this is where it
gets a little bit challenging I but I
think this one is still fairly obvious
given the retirement of Rob Gronkowski
Benjamin Watson is back in New England
he suspended the first four games Dwayne
Allen is gone although who the hell is
gonna play tight end for the New England
Patriots they got everything else
especially with Josh Gordon back they
don't have tight ends Patriots tight end
Achilles heel for the team that most
believed will be at least in the final
four if not back in the Superbowl in
2019 all right so here's where I
disagree with this pick the Patriots
they change year to year there's no one
better in the game than changing what
the DNA of a team is then Bill Belichick
so just because they have don't have
Robin Kowski doesn't mean they won't be
successful switching it up you saw it
last year when the they didn't have that
deep threat when Josh Gordon leaves the
team they become a running team a power
team what's to say they can't just
switch it back if Josh Gordon comes back
and now they're throwing it deep so I I
don't think that's really an Achilles
heel
it doesn't feel it feels like you would
you know the doctor has a very quick fix
for that and his name is Bill Belichick
well I'm evil say and you know what the
quick fix may eventually be Tom Brady
getting on the phone with Rob Gronkowski
and saying come back because I've been
told that as it relates to Rob
Gronkowski possibly Unruh tiring a huge
factor in that would be a personal plea
from Tom Brady to get him to come back
so maybe it's not an Achilles heel
because he won't come back I don't want
under my my own pick but for now going
into the season I see it as an Achilles
heel all right what do you got you just
did you undermine your own pick all
right my next one another health
I don't know why it's so hard for you to
understand Achilles heel I'm just gonna
say the chargers health overall because
this has happened in the last few years
where they seem to lose big key pieces
early Derwin James already on the list
so it's already feels like it's
happening the Chargers are that team
that we've been talking about for the
last few years of can they take that
next step
are they Super Bowl worthy and it feels
like the injuries have always been their
Achilles heel Mike yeah but there's some
again it's so widespread it's like here
we go again it's not an Achilles heel it
is that they don't have they don't have
their basic level of protection they
they they they don't have armor they're
going into battle naked that's the
problem with the Chargers they always
have these injuries they always have
these issues to the point where and I
say this all the time when you only so
much can be attributed to bad luck and
we'll see every week there are guys who
get their bodies pretzeled up and they
bounce back and they're fine Alexander
Madison the other night and that
Seahawks Vikings game I thought he had a
torn ACL he stayed in the game and he
ran the ball the next play at some level
it's about your training staff your
everything about what you do to get your
guys ready to play and to keep them on
the field and and for the Chargers
they're one of the teams where that
alarm has to be going off it's so much
it's just like Andrew Luck it's so much
bigger than it Kelly's heel in my view
okay well I just another injury and it's
throwing James another foot injury
similar to the Achilles heel all right
there are so many that I can choose from
we may need to go four rounds here if we
have enough time I'm gonna go with the
Steelers number two receiver position
I've heard a lot of different names and
there's been a lot of optimism whether
it's Donte Moncrief James Washington
Deante Johnson but you're moving juju
Smith Schuster who was great
who was phenomenal as the number two
receiver last year a guy who won the
team MVP award as the number two
receiver he now moves over to number one
he gets all the attention that goes
along with it the running backs are
going to get a certain amount of
attention it's going to create an
opportunity for that number two receiver
to draw favorable matchups to get open
and to make things happen and if this
dealers offense is going to work to the
it needs to to make people forget about
Antonio Brown and Le'Veon Bell they need
a number two receiver to step up but I
just think that right now they don't
know who the hell it's gonna be what the
guy is gonna do and that's got the
potential to be a problem for the
Steelers this year as they do you know
it's been a weird kind of a life cycle
for the Steelers off season they've gone
from having no expectations to kind of
there's a sense hey you know what they
actually have high expectations and
they're pissed off at everybody and
they're rallying around each other and
they're gonna have a good year they need
to have a good performance out of the
number two receiver and that could be
the Achilles heels for the Steelers
offense or for the entire team but if
you throw out the Chargers and say
they're always injured you have to throw
out the Steelers here because they
always find a way with wide receivers I
wouldn't be worried whatsoever they
always find a way up but that's the
Achilles heel because if they don't
that'll be the thing that causes them to
fall apart
okay well another bad pick by you I'll
go my last pick I'll go with the Chiefs
secondary they've tried to fix it a
little bit you know they bring in Tyrone
mantel it's slander the honey badger I'm
knocking a slinger to the honey badger
they're trying to fix it but that will
be what does the Chiefs in we know the
offense will be there they had I think
there was second worst in past defense
last year you remember the AFC
Championship game it felt like the once
Tom Brady got rolling and Julian Edelman
in that fourth quarter and overtime they
could get whatever they wanted every
single play they ran almost the same
play over and over and the Chiefs had no
answer so the Chiefs have a Superbowl
caliber team they have Andy Reed Patrick
mahomes you name it if they get done in
it's going to be that secondary not
showing up in the big moments
all right stats tells me we've got time
for around four do you have another pick
yeah are you ready to get older all
right Cam Newton shoulder boom wait a
minute if I turn it's a killer shoulder
turn you die I wasn't gonna take Cam
Newton shorter I'm gonna say the Eagles
backup quarterback situation I love Josh
McCown but all of a sudden they're
bringing him off of the analyst desk at
ESPN to come in and be number two not
not just kind of be there to be the
veteran presence he's number two behind
Carson Wentz he's in the nick foles spot
and we've seen what the Nick Foles spot
is he
in the last two years you're gonna play
at some point and I don't know that Josh
McCown is gonna be able to step in
figure out that offense perform the way
that he needs to if and when the
opportunity arises if not him it's Nate
Sud felt it's Thurston Howell the third
I don't know what's going on with the
backup quarterback position in
Philadelphia but it is critical because
of Carson Wentz's tendency to get
injured so for me round for Eagles
backup quarterback situation and for you
it's Cam Newton and that shoulder that
either is or isn't healed with a new
throwing motion and who knows how he's
gonna play and who knows whether he's
gonna be able to throw the ball and who
knows whether or not he's gonna be able
to stay healthy so I can't disagree with
that one either all right I mean I
dominated this draft including the
fourth round because again I don't think
I think we have a totally different
understanding of Achilles heel here if
the Eagles if Carson Wentz does not if
he gets hurt their season is over oh
like it was two years ago when they won
the Superbowl like oh they're fools is
little different they couldn't pass
you're making my point
no Achilles heel they don't have a
backup quarterback that they can feel as
good about as they felt about Nick Foles
come on man Carson Wentz's body is their
Achilles heel that's a couple of others
that I consider and then we got to take
a break I had Chiefs running back
situation as a potential Achilles heel
on that offense the Cowboys stubbornness
Todd Gurley zni and I love for any
kitchens but the Browns coaching if it
doesn't work in Cleveland that's gonna
be the thing that could be the undoing
so the only other one out add is you
started with the Bears kicking I
actually would say it's the Bears injury
lock more than anything last year they
didn't have that big big injury Eddie
Jackson got injured towards the end of
the year the Khalil Mack missed a couple
games injury Luck is a fickle thing in
the NFL and if you can't stay healthy a
team staying healthy throughout the year
it can switch on you just like that
dude you just chased your team don't you
jinx the Bears yes always being honest
Mike I can take a power to juice
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports